it's been called north korea's most
significant weapons test in years the
reclusive regime has confirmed it has
launched a missile that can reach u.s
bases in the pacific state media said
the weapon was a hwasong-12 that's a
ballistic missile of intermediate range
it is capable of hitting the u.s
territory of guam with a nuclear warhead
it's the first time the north has tested
a missile that size since 2017. the
report said pictures of the earth were
taken in space from the missile's nose
cone
its flight was first detected by
neighboring south korea and japan which
condemned the test
the series of actions by north korea
including the repeated launches of
ballistic missiles threatened the peace
and security of japan the region and the
international community
such intense ballistic missile launches
are in violation of relevant security
council resolutions
and our country has made a strong
protest to north korea
tomorrow i'm joined by josh smith he's a
senior correspondent with the reuters
news agency in seoul josh we keep
hearing about these tests in south korea
and japan and the us have been quick to
voice their concern do we need to be
concerned
so all of these missiles have been
smaller than the really large
intercontinental ballistic missiles that
got a lot of attention back in 2017 when
north korea tested them those are the
ones that could reach as far as the
united states but one thing that
analysts have increasingly pointed out
and that officials here in seoul and
japan as you mentioned have said
is that these missiles that north korea
has developed lately are increasingly
capable
and they are the types that could be
potentially used in
the case of war ever breaks out and so
for
people that are down here potentially in
the firing line you know amid all of
these tensions
it is something that is very concerning
and military analysts and officials
alike say that north korea is making
real progress in increasing these
capabilities they're not for sure show
they're not purely a propaganda tool
they do have real military uh
we talked about the propaganda there
this was the biggest missile north korea
has tested since 2017 and follows months
of smaller tests however contrary to
2017 there's been far less of the
bombasts and the shrill threats from
pyongyang this time around can we make
anything of this
that's correct there has been much less
talk of fire and fury that we saw in in
2017
north korea has mentioned its uh
displeasure with the united states
particularly with sanctions and with
ongoing military activities by the
united states and south korea here um
but it's really all of its state media
coverage of most of these tests have
really focused on the technical aspects
of it and leader kim jong-un only showed
up at one of the seven tests unlike many
of the tests back in 2017 and this is
something that analysts point to as
evidence that north korea is in many
ways trying to normalize
its tests in fact get the world to
accept that these are normal uh
self-defense uh operations by a country
uh that is just trying to protect itself
let's have a look at the timing of this
test uh while diplomats are working
around the clock at the moment to
prevent
a russian invasion in ukraine relations
with china at their worst in years
what do you read into the timing of this
missile test
so there are a lot of internal things
going on in north korea outside of that
this comes ahead of some very key
holidays that they usually like to
show a display of their military power
around and they of course have some
economic crises so this is uh in part a
way for the government to show strength
in the face of those problems
at the same time
analysts and officials that we talked to
have noted that north korea could be
taking advantage of a bit of distraction
by a lot of the world
you know it's seeking to continue to
make these real uh military advances at
a time when uh the united states its
allies other countries around the world
only have so much bandwidth to
concentrate on calculating perhaps that
they can make some progress
with less of the attention that they got
in the past
josh smith there in seoul for us thank
you josh
thank you
you